[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos hablando del caso
de una niña española que podría ayudar a
identificar una causa genética del lupus
en principio recordemos que es una
enfermedad autoinmune crónica y compleja
que puede afectar las articulaciones el
cerebro los pulmones los riñones la piel
y los vasos sanguíneos provoca
inflamación generalizada y daño del
tejido en los órganos afectados pues los
científicos identificaron una mutación
en el gen tlr7 que activa en la membrana
de las células un receptor llamado de la
misma forma tlr7 normalmente sirve para
reconocer virus amenazantes pero en
gabriela piqueras esta niña española su
mecanismo de acción es elevado y
reacciona ante su propio adn lo que
desata un ataque a sus propios órganos
y gabriela tiene una mutación en el gen
tlr7 esa mutación hace que el receptor
del r7 reconozca nuestros propios ácidos
nucleicos nuestro propio adn y rn como
si fuera un microbio
así que cantidades muy pequeñas de estos
ácidos nucleicos se convierten en un
desencadenante para el tlr7 las células
reaccionan de forma normal sobre
reaccionan cuando no hay una infección
viral habria las antillas en otras
palabras la mutación hace que las
células inmunes se confundan y crean que
deben actuar contra un microbio que no
existe tras descubrir esta mutación
sospechosa el equipo científico la
replicó en una familia de ratones en su
laboratorio de la universidad nacional
australiana en canberra los roedores
también desarrollaron la enfermedad el
descubrimiento ha permitido que los
expertos le den a gabriela un
tratamiento más adecuado lo que hace que
ya no sufra espasmos involuntarios ahora
cabe aclarar que no todas las personas
que desarrollan lupus lo hacen por esta
alteración genética por la secuenciación
completa del genoma del adn es clave
para determinar si los pacientes sufren
la mutación
y encontrar la mutación en gabriela nos
llevó a probar que una actividad
aumentada del tlr7 es patógeno en el
lupus es una de las causas del lupus
habrá muchos otros pacientes que no
tengan estas raras mutaciones pero
pueden tener actividad aumentada en el
tl r7 por otras causas ya sea una
combinación de mutaciones más leves ya
sea en el gen tlr7 o en los genes
posteriores o debido a estímulos
ambientales como infecciones hachas
infecciones los investigadores explican
que el gen tlr7 se encuentra en el
cromosoma sexual x los hombres tienen
uno solo de estos cromosomas el par es y
mientras que las mujeres tienen dos
cromosomas x esto podría explicar por
qué el lupus afecta más a mujeres que a
hombres este descubrimiento puede ser
clave para desarrollar tratamientos más
personalizados que se encarguen de los
niveles del receptor tlr7 el lupus no
tiene cura y actualmente es tratado con
inmunosupresores que reducen la fuerza
de acción del sistema inmunológico
para suavizar los síntomas no obstante
esto deja a los pacientes expuestos a
contraer más fácilmente infecciones una
medicación específica podría ayudar a
miles de personas de hecho ya hay
estudios avanzando con fármacos que
buscan controlar los niveles de tlr7
vamos ahora al reino unido donde fue
inaugurado el one el primer puerto para
drones y futuros vehículos eléctricos
que despeguen y aterricen verticalmente
por ello se ha llamado berti puerto la
instalación está ubicada en una vieja
central de fabricación de automóviles en
coventry en el centro de inglaterra
el vuelo de inauguración lo realiza un
dron comercial prestado por el ejército
británico llevó una caja con seis
botellas de vino espumoso que pesaban
unos 12 kilogramos
estamos parados sobre el primer puerto
aéreo urbano completamente operativo del
mundo y un puerto aéreo urbano es una
pieza de infraestructura de aviación
entonces usarás uno de estos para tomar
un taxi aéreo a otra ciudad u otra
ubicación muy pronto muy pronto
los taxis aéreos de pasajeros ya se
están certificando algunos apuntan a
poder funcionar en 2024 solo faltan dos
años en its y des way la instalación fue
diseñada para parecerse a un aeropuerto
con un salón puertas de seguridad y un
área de despegue para que los pasajeros
que viajen en taxis a otros puntos de la
ciudad oa otras ciudades gocen de todas
las comodidades
y lo más urgente a demostrar es cómo
funcionarán estos vehículos de los que
todos han oído hablar taxis voladores
autos voladores drones de carga drones
logísticos se congestionaran los cielos
estarán realmente ocupados con los
drones
buenos la respuesta es no siempre y
cuando haya una infraestructura
coordinada en el terreno y no way
entonces literalmente estamos allanando
el camino poniendo la infraestructura en
su lugar lo cual la compañía responsable
de este vertido planea construir 200 de
ellos en todo el mundo durante los
próximos cinco años cada uno costará
entre 6 y 12 millones de dólares y puede
ser edificado en 11 semanas en ese mismo
tiempo puede ser desmontado en caso de
que los estudios muestran que es más
eficiente ubicar el puerto en otra zona
y finalizamos en marte porque la cámara
del explorador percibir ons logró captar
un eclipse solar en el planeta rojo las
imágenes muestran el momento en que
fobos una de las lunas de marte
característica por su forma de papá pasó
frente al sol de acuerdo con la nasa el
vídeo detalla la observación más amplia
y con mayor velocidad de fotogramas de
un eclipse solar que jamás haya sido
tomada en la superficie de este planeta
el avistamiento duró aproximadamente 40
segundos y ocurrió el pasado 2 de abril
el día marciano número 397 de su año así
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
as
a